Memorial Day weekend is here and with at
the start of the summer travel season
more than 41 million Americans are
expected to travel this weekend the most
since 2005 that of course means crowded
airports long lines and jammed highways
here to tell us what to expect is
Jacqueline Gifford travel director of
Travel and Leisure magazines jackie
welcome good morning first of all well
higher gas prices where more people
traveling by Road or by air actually
most of those folks are traveling by
Road about 37 million if you can believe
that but even though gas prices are
higher they're making up for it because
hotel prices on average or lower and car
rental prices are lower so and about 3
million people will be flying this
weekend so again this is a record year
of 5 percent from last year it's really
encouraging it's an encouraging sign for
the economy we've seen over the past few
years people are really valuing travel
valuing experiences over things so I
think it's just a symptom of that we're
just getting into the summer travels
yeah how about tips for people saving
time and money as they look ahead sure
so one thing I like to suggest that you
should do is set a fair alert if you
know where you want to go you just all
you have to do is go to a site like
Google flights airfare watchdog or use
an app called hopper which I love
they're gonna notify you if it looks
like the flight price is gonna drop
another thing that I would suggest doing
is being a little bit flexible about
your travel schedule you know people
have busy lives they've got their kids
camp they've got work but if you're a
little bit flexible over over a couple
days you might save a couple hundred
dollars the cheapest days to fly
historically are Tuesdays Wednesdays and
Saturdays and the last tip I suggest
actually cashing in your points and
miles people like to [ __ ] them they
like to see these big it's hard to let
them go I'm guilty myself I just did it
and you know what it was great I'm like
letting those building again alright you
have a few favorite easy getaways let's
start with the first one Charleston
South Carolina it's so beautiful right
here on the East Coast I mean it's just
the quintessential southern city got a
ton of great historical sites to see
it's on the water
I'm also it's a really big food town
right you can go from everything to a
formal restaurant to great barbecue I
just love Charleston
and also it's a really family friendly
destination there are tons of barrier
islands near the cities you can go to
the beaches great hotels it's just a you
know a great place if you like food and
you like history Mackinac Island a place
I know very well yes so on Lake Michigan
it's kind of a time capsule right you
know it it's got this Victorian era
charm to it no cars allowed on the
island people still travel by
horse-drawn carriage if you can believe
it all these little charming shops
there's a revolutionary airport just
lots to do finally in the Rocky
Mountains Telluride Colorado Telluride
so a lot of people go there to ski in
the winter but the summer it's just as
beautiful you can go mountain biking and
hiking they're famous for their charming
little town the main street it's like
stepping back into the Wild West lots to
do there and in terms of outdoor
activities all those are great
suggestions for the weekend we actually
we hope most people that dodge the rain
but all right Jackie Gifford thanks so
much for being with us thank you